hello welcome to a new video um this
will be somewhat different and you can
video for this channel so what i'm doing
here is some i'm following um an online
blitz match here and do some live
commentary on that so I'm not playing
myself but rather key bits in here um
this is played on the the ICC the
internet chess club and the players some
facing each other here are here playing
why this is here with the handle eros
this is international master Eric Hanson
from Canada I think some of you might
know him because he is some long time
play on chest cube very successful blitz
and bullet player on the server and his
garden insanely high rating also on icc
close to 3300 which is among the best
bit blitz players them on icc and he am
playing black this is Grand Master
Maxime vashi lagrave from France he's
some I think number one or number two of
France and rated close to or slightly
below at the moment I'm not quite sure
2,700 ello so he's um yeah let's say not
not completely top world-class but not
so far away he's played his share of
super tournaments okay so lots of
introduction yeah this is a three minute
blitz game and we've got done we had a
Queen's Indian game here Queens Indian
structure and the main feature of this
position here this black sphere pressure
down the e-file on the Pawnee to and I
think black should be it should be quite
good here White has problems on the
e-file and also slightly we king
position only slide weakness some for
black guess he knew
to take care of this a 4 porn and this
d4 pawn is also yeah close to loss but
you always have this counter pressure on
you to so black should be really okay
here if wide now covers eat ooh and
black would I think most likely played
just rook to e4 e720 for to keep d4 and
then trying to put more pressure but ok
why decided to take on deform our queen
of five is interesting black also could
have just taken on deform and entered
only two with the rookwood this is
certainly would be a would have been
quite good for black but he sacrificed
the porn him and this way keeping the
Queen's on I'm not sure that this is
really better like now pawn down and
he's trying to UM yeah get the ad most
activity here I mean it's hard to
imagine that white should be better here
with this extra porn because he just
tied down to e3 and defending his sis
with his weakness but i'm not sure i
think maybe this simple recapture on
youtube was was better white seems able
to to handle this it's still not easy to
play though
we are needs to get rid of one rook here
but now it's it's kind of tricky
tweenage oneness and possibility and
you've got all kinds of stuff now Queen
f3 green h2 mostly sir quite
uncomfortable position yeah now black
hood could just take h2 and you would
get the oh interesting
quite I just think I would have just
taken edge to a couple of moves before
but yeah it's so um it still seems some
very complicated here Black's got the
Jeep on but widescreen on f5 is Sir
quite a good piece to generate count
play against the king and blacks Queen
doesn't really attack the king at the
moment so I'm not so sure about this
position
yeah why tries to just capture 33 and
maybe he'll manage could have uh no
rookie three now so black black black is
now attacking why not rookie three just
look better to me but well why doesn't
serious time trouble my Black now has no
check yeah and what this was a huge
blunder right now right now with a
meeting attack yeah I think like a
sports his chances day was very good but
okay three minutes is a tough time
control okay we've got an English
opening okay now transposing to the
fianchetto Greenfeld o Queen B fork yeah
this this happens with pre moves I'll
see that the white player here i'm
disconnected so um he was kind of had a
p.m. yeah of course Knight a5 is the
normal move in this position and he went
Quincy to pre move which didn't really
didn't really work too well here so
let's see if there's some some other
game that I could follow here I prefer
I'm three or five minute of course
because leave some time to really do do
some comentary in the meantime I might
switch on this this bullet game here and
here playing this was arcade the game is
already already ended here
don't see such a highly rated blitz of
five minute game yeah here we have a one
minute game white players a whole girl
Sam Mahesh Boone she's some pretty well
known blitz player but it's just a
blunder two piece here again so another
Grand Master all right doesn't have a
name in there Camela which no idea yeah
unfortunately am we didn't have a real
match here because Rashida graph i left
the server after this Queen blunder so
um let's see what else is on there
yeah we have from deuel here between
international master pretty high rated
on the five-minute pool against an
international master from Germany yeah
mr. Sontag here and we've got I think
this must have been a ruler peso yeah
roul Lopez kind of structure will why
dumb managed to drum up some play on the
F file here black look so very
uncomfortable yeah white certainly
doesn't like to exchange Queens but it
still keeps keeps him some advantage I
would really consider Queen edge for
here trying to play with Queens on the
board Queen h 4f five is not possible
because seven is hanging so I'm not
quite sure where white would want to
exchange Queens another possibility is
also rook rook takes f6 rook f6 Bishop
f6 rook f6 and the position with Queen
takes h6 Bishop h6 would be brilliant
for white because you control the FR and
black is close to ya you cannot move
would be huge for white I think rook
takes f6 is very strong now
or at least out so something you should
should really consider not quite sure
what white is doing here I mean rook
takes f6 is good and Queen edge for
assault so good is really using this
time here just to repeat what I was was
mentioning this rook takes f6 Bishop f6
rook takes f6 and then queen edge 6
bishop age 6 you have this Bishop Bishop
on age 6 and this rook on f6 controlling
f8 so black and never play rock f8d 6 is
hanging and it's not possible to protect
this I think white is flat-out winning
here Queen edge for also great I think
he's got some some connection problem
right doesn't make any sense yeah
thought of disconnected very unlucky
selection of games here because people
just blunder staff forum or get
disconnected ESO white will do so due to
this connection here but it's quite
interesting motive here rook takes f6
unfortunately I cannot can move here
because it's not my game but this is
quite strong and then interesting kind
of motif to to remember this bishop on
h6 coming of all right yeah
unfortunately can I move now actually
yeah I can this I can I can also switch
up the computer just to to help me a bit
so what I was thinking of is this
position and now I'm controlling the f8
square I'm only move for black is root
g8 now this is actually still playable
for black because Ruby success is very
useful so this kind of stuff
yeah why it still has very fine
compensation for the exchange but it's
not flat out winning so maybe I'm maybe
just um
also just queen edge for as good alright
let's see if you got some other game
here and a very much progressed game
already oops yeah that's a bit unlucky
to have no real Grandmaster blitz match
here so this game that I am selected a
couple of seconds ago here features an
international math on the black side and
white here's some Russian player the
truth without any name attention he's
also got very few game so this is some
most likely some Russian Grand Master
who this could also be a secondary
account an anonymous account so I'm yeah
position is quite symmetrical looking
but White has the extra a porn so um why
does sound much better here and he's
also have has a huge time advantage you
pretty much played all this instantly
yeah now white tries to exchange rooks
and it's hard to prevent if wyd manages
to get rid of queens and rooks then the
a porn would simply promote okay black
tries to prevent the rook exchange but
why it has some I think more than one
good option here everything else fails
you can play Quincy five sort of really
trying to exchange Queens and after
Quincy five black don't know doesn't
have really good move can exchange
Queens but just let out losers he am
elected to push the a poem but now black
gum try to go Queenie one here trying
for counter play and um I'm not sure if
I like this really so wyd moves like c5
here might be irritating attacking the
rook
roo k 8 and hmm I'm not quite sure that
that really has something but it looks a
bit shaky all this yeah hmm yeah this is
more than shaking off or black actually
what what is he doing to to protect his
bishop here
I think this is just just getting lost
right yeah black loses a piece now
okay some desperado sacrifice mmm I mean
white can also just take what the King I
think on Queen g1 check just Queen Shh
oh no this is actually not so great King
takes Queen g1 checks Quincy to Quincy
to kingi to Bishop h3 and okay this
still wins for white because of the a
porn okay but them there may be
something something clearer I'm check
with the porn queen III you might
actually threaten Queen f2 some sort of
perpetual hmm yeah just take what the
king I mean this justice when skin takes
Queen g1 you might be able to even play
king h4 but this is not the kind of move
you love to play in a blitz game but
even even this sort of rook blunder
Queen g2 just wins I think King takes
Queen g1 check Quincy to takes King
takes Bishop h3 check King h3 rook takes
be eight and then a 5a five a-six
a-seven is just pushes through I think
one this outside pass porn and the the
bishop pair to support it usually as
some is just deadly let's see what
happens king queen g1's the idea and
maybe even go see IEP does this the King
knows this is some possibly just winning
instantly because it's it's really
nothing a parent here g5 has covered
black might try to it check the porn
queen h2 yeah you may be simply play
Queen f3 then uh huh wow this is really
am and nothing here
it still looks a bit dangerous go into
mg6 with the idea Queen g6 yeah maybe
it's all working out black only to head
down to 12 seconds and this mode
threatened g-form to check at least but
this is also no made King edge for and
the King just creeps back to g3 and
Bishop f4 and and it's that such I think
well this was the last check really rook
takes off a thread now yeah yeah pretty
pretty clear clear winner for white um I
think it's another game that might be
interesting this is here armed composer
oops well this Camilla which I don't
know who's the black Grandmaster here
why does in a minion Grandmaster I think
Robert of Phoenician either I think
junior world champion from last year or
two years ago or something pretty young
player a wide already one here so I'm a
bit of a late join me in the game sorry
I didn't really realize that this game
is actually over um so what what is the
point here yeah why does widest indeed
winning the bishop bungee three years
mp3s attacked and it's just getting lost
or black plays Bishop c4 after which
white can exchange Bishop and grab c2
and then you will play King c3 c4 and
just push the ape on the apron supported
here by the rook should should win
pretty easily
so um yeah I've got more bullet games
here which doesn't really make so much
sense to to do comments on I've got this
Camilla which guy again here against
Vaska but this is a Larry Chris Jensen
Grandmaster questions and he Sam yeah
really kind of bullet edict you see him
play out I okay we've got another free
minute game here um Eric Hanson again
here against off Shannon easy on I'm
certainly butchering this kind of
pronunciation a three minute let's scare
me and the three minute Otto pairing and
both are really ridiculously highly
rated here 26 and 25 is amazingly I ok
so we've got a wretched opening him wide
fianchetto in both bishops and now black
managed to manage to get rid of one
Bishop p.m. I'm fairly solid position
for black who set up this solid Slav
like semi Slav like poor information
with see 66 and so on and whites main
idea here is to play on the queenside as
we see you push before now c5 and might
try to ya find some useful role for his
bishop the g two bishops now not the
strongest piece but it can potentially
become stronger later I de force
surprising to me ok and this was the
idea I wanted to to get them get to
recapture in this way so um I'm not
quite sure if this is so promising for
for white you can yeah exactly you can
get this kind of structure here in which
um the only idea to to activate your
bishop is to play before and I'm not
sure that he manages this on the on the
good side circle
stanzas the other idea would be to to
play for the b5 break and in the
meantime Black has activated his night
also putting pressure on a three
now whiter needs to be cautious en this
b5 move also entails some slight risk
that the c5 pawn becomes vulnerable so
you have some activity yourself but need
to be cautious about this pawn because
c5 cannot be unprotected with your
bishop you also cannot play f3 so it's a
bit double-edged ok so now white um p1's
could take on a form getting rid of the
night ok I see made my tries to play f32
ok and just made some improving hooves
and then exchanged
so rookie six now protecting c6 yeah
white has some the better King here it's
already close to the default square and
black it's a bit but less active here a4
and c6 is somewhat weaker than the c5
pawn it helped wide to to exchange the
bishop for the night so that he doesn't
really need to worry about c5 all the
time but still it some fairly solid for
black but um some very likely that some
this might um end up in really draw
position of course the time is always a
factor so it's I'm not saying that that
won't happen anything in this game but
don't think black has so much to fear
okay now it gets in more interesting
again because white sacrificed F to pawn
for getting a form but this is a bit
risky also black will get bonds on the
King side but needs to return the rook
also to to stop those pawns I know he's
trying to push the H porn
okay this was very strong taking Andrew
cage 6 this should be a winning end game
now for white I think cool resource
cannot capture us all because Lucas
hanging and cool cool move and he was
threatening F form it might doesn't help
anything but good good try to defend
yeah White has the am the sea poem that
you can that you can use and the edge
pond cannot really move at best you
exchange the world's H porn and white
still has those two outside passes we
are here here here kicking c5 comes into
consideration King c5 to d6 yeah and now
he is playing it the end and defend our
45 with okay this this just promote the
porn and c8 queen okay made to meet
coming up I think with ya Queen a8 made
all this made yeah pretty interesting
endgame I think this transformation arm
at the end was quite good for white but
very complicated kind of position
difficult to to play on with such a slow
such lower low time yeah this kind of
transformation a porn for F porn it's
some very difficult to to play of course
when you're so down on time so let's see
if we got some some other game here that
might be worth watching
okay we've got what is this five-minute
game I don't have any names black as an
international master here with two for
something rating and wide 2200 player
but also from the US I've got some kind
of old Indian structure well black gum
exchange the c8 bishop on on f3 so white
has the bishop am and like doesn't
really have any concrete compensation
for this so why should be okay what I'm
wondering about um it's um like
threatening night XD five now and it
takes d5 or maybe queen a for ya mmhmm
yeah yeah 95 is always a tactical idea
with this Bishop Vaughn g5 when this
Bishop is loose so what I didn't think
it was working because of Queen a form
so no why dumb
white could simply play a three I think
pushing pushing the night back okay well
don't like that so much giving up your
your your bishop of course the position
is fairly close so you can argue that
bishops are not so great but the
positions yeah closed positions are very
often open up but once the position is
opened it never closes down so um this
is some pretty basic reason why bishops
off and better than nights because of
the simple fact positions are hard to
close down but often more easy to open
to give your bishop some room okay so
what do we have here why didn't really
try to punish black voice kind of setup
and now um I actually don't understand
how wide isn't pushing the night back
but III don't don't who doesn't want to
okay but now I disconnect yeah great I'm
not so lucky here with and with my game
selection and I think it could could
have become pretty interesting a kind of
maneuvering game with with f4 and f5
breaks to to come and some play on the
on the King side alright so I don't
think I was so lucky with with the games
here um I also did this kind of video
too yes sort of ask you um if you if you
like the idea of doing those kind of
cubed sing of course this wasn't the
gray wasn't the greatest 30 minutes over
here because I had so many disconnects
and blunders and whatever but please
write write something and reply on the
video if you like the general idea that
I do this and once in a while
of course i'd like to play myself and
yeah sort of hope to understand my own
games better my own ideas better than if
i just watch other other people play but
it might be an interesting kind of
change once in a while to do this
comments so yeah please let me know how
you like the the general idea that I do
this once in a while alright thanks for
watching and talk to you soon in a new
video